i found out a little bit of why people
seem to not like elon musk i just don't
get it i don't get what everyone's
problem is right i said the elon musk
hate is so weird to me people hate
success yeah literally because that's
what it is they hate success and they're
losing is it a jealous thing though it's
not jealousy what ends up happening this
happens in every single society
is that if you go back 200 years 100
years even 50 years ago the united
states of america put a flag in the
ground and they said we are going to
allow anyone in the world regardless of
education wealth where they were born
what language they speak what religion
they have or literally what their
beliefs on anything are
if you make it to the united states
the land of opportunity you will be
allowed to pursue a life of happiness
and financial security and we will do
everything in our power to help make
that happen
and if you come here
and you help build our country because
we are a capitalistic democratic society
you will reap the benefits
we will not take from you we will
instead encourage small businesses
entrepreneurship value creation
innovation technology etc and it worked
america went from we weren't even on the
map
we didn't even exist a couple hundred
years ago
to the greatest country in the world
the most prosperous country in the world
the most democratic free country in the
world
and along the way
there's a bunch of people who didn't do
[ __ ]
the freeloaders the free riders
and they watched as the country grew
and they got soft they got complacent
and once they got soft and complacent
they then started to look around and say
to themselves
why does that man have that stuff and i
don't
why does that man get that stuff
and that other person over there doesn't
and the answer is
because he
created the electric vehicle industry in
the united states
he and his team are the first people to
create a [ __ ] rocket that goes up in
the air and re lands on a drone ship in
the ocean
he did what nasa couldn't do by being
able to create reusable rockets
he
is the first person to figure out to
solve traffic maybe we should dig holes
in the ground and do it efficiently and
cost effectively
and you can go down the line and he's
created all this value
that's why he has what he has because he
created value
why does jeff bezos have 200 billion
dollars because you press a [ __ ]
button on your phone and food shows up
and if you had created that idea and
made it work
you'd have 200 billion too
but you don't
and not only does food show up
but also
he has cloud computing he created the
largest bookstore in the world he's
created a marketplace that literally
does 50 of e-commerce in the united
states
if you want to be rich create value
if you want to complain
get on the internet and don't do [ __ ]
that's ultimately what we're talking
about here and at some point we got to
take the gloves off
and say the people who are complaining
about what elon musk is doing
they're free riders
they're benefiting from all the value
creation of entrepreneurs and
technologists
they're not creating the value
but they complaining about it
but i promise you they use twitter which
elon musk now owns to complain about
elon musk while they drive down the road
that is now safer because there's
electric vehicles that have self-driving
on it and uber to take drunk drivers off
of the road and then they get to their
office which has drastically been
increased their uh efficiency and
productivity by all the technology and
all the entrepreneurship that happened
and oh by the way
they are probably part of the over 50 of
americans that don't pay taxes but
benefit from all the government programs
and other government activities
elon musk
stroked an 11 billion dollar check to
the government with their attack with
his taxes last year
50 of americans didn't pay
at the end of the day
the way a capitalistic society works
if you create value you get rewarded if
you don't create value you don't get
rewarded that's it point blank period
and the earlier you learn in your life
no one's coming to save you you are not
guaranteed [ __ ]
create value you get a reward
if you don't create value you don't get
the reward that's how the world works
and anyone who's telling you any other
dream they're probably a socialist and
go study all the examples in history how
that doesn't work
end rant hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time